michael saylor and microstrategy are at
it again they already hold billions and
billions of dollars worth of bitcoin
they're the first publicly traded
company to put bitcoin on their balance
sheet but now they are pioneering a
brand new strategy to acquire more
bitcoin this morning michael saylor
announced that macro strategy a
subsidiary of microstrategy has closed a
205 million dollar bitcoin
collateralized loan with silvergate bank
to purchase bitcoin ultimately what
they're doing is they're actually
borrowing money using their bitcoin on
their balance sheet as part of the
collateral to secure that loan that 205
million dollars will be used to not only
pay the interest and fees on the loan
but also to go ahead and acquire more
bitcoin this is what happens when
somebody who understands capital markets
and has a bitcoin thesis begins to get
to work now if we go ahead and we take a
look at microstrategy itself and what
they hold on their balance sheet what we
see is that microstrategy currently
holds about 125 000 bitcoin that they
acquired for 3.78 billion dollars their
average price point is about 30 000
at 48 000 on bitcoin they hold
approximately six billion dollars of
bitcoin that is big time stuff now we've
got a quote here from alan lane the
silvergate ceo in which he stated that
they're thrilled to add microstrategy to
their growing list of the silver gate
leveraged borrowers their innovative
approach to treasury management is an
exceptional example of how institutions
can utilize their bitcoin to support and
grow their business and then michael
saylor had a quote where he stated that
the leveraged loan gives them an
opportunity to further their position as
the leading public company investor in
bitcoin using the capital from the loan
we've effectively turned our bitcoin
into productive collateral which allows
us to further execute against our
business strategy now ultimately we are
going to see this play out more and more
bitcoin is pristine collateral and
whether you have it on your balance
sheet or in your personal portfolio more
people are gonna realize that they're
able to actually borrow against that
asset you can't get over leveraged you
can't get crazy with it but to watch
microstrategy take a 205 million dollar
loan against six billion dollars in
bitcoin i think what they're gonna do is
they're gonna end up orange pilling an
entire new class of financial investors
wall street hedge funds and publicly
traded companies ultimately michael
saylor and microstrategy are executing
one of the highest conviction trades in
wall street history they're going all in
on bitcoin and something tells me it's
going to continue to work just fine for
them hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time